As you can tell, I’m really excited for today’s
lesson with one of my childhood favorites!
It’s the story about the hawaiian girl who wanted a cute dog
and instead got a terrifying extraterrestrial lifeform: Lilo & Stitch!
So this lesson is special because you will learn a bit about Hawaiian-American
culture and vocabulary related to dogs and for talking to animals.
But before we get into that, I want to invite you newcomers to join our community
of over 4 Million learners who are discovering how FUN learning English can be.
Like Ha who says that their listening and
speaking is now improving really fast!
So every week we make 3 lessons to help you understand fast-speech
without getting lost, without missing the jokes, and without subtitles,
but if you don’t hit that subscribe button and
the bell down below, you might miss them!
Alright, so as you saw in this clip, Stitch is marked by his mischievous
behavior, but in fact this is what endeared him to Lilo,
who adopted him as her "dog". We’re now going to watch
the moment when Lilo and Stitch first meet.
Do you ever feel frustrated when native speakers don’t speak like you expect and you
can’t understand? If you are like most learners, then you emphatically said YES!
Well, we created our Fluent with Friends course to help
you master native pronunciation and connected speech,
so that you can confidently understand fast native speech.
And you will have so much fun learning with this timeless series.
Give it a try for free! You can sign up by clicking up
here or down in the description below.
Many learners get confused by HIM and THEM because we
natives often pronounce them the same.  It’s crazy, right?
Well, pronunciation expert Rachel helped us explain
this strange pronunciation in this lesson.
You can watch that after you finish this one by clicking
up here or down in the description below.
All right, get ready to test everything you’ve learned today!
And after you finish the quiz, if you want an even bigger challenge,
then I recommend you download our free RealLifeApp
where you can practice speaking English
with other learners from around the world at the touch of a button. So, for example,
you can try using some of the new vocabulary that you learned with Lilo & Stitch,
or ask someone about their favorite Disney movies!
To download that for free and start speaking English
you can click the link in the description, or simply search for RealLife
English in the Apple App or Google Play store. See you there!